okay Wow okay I'm surprised I'm hosting
this all right okay this is a really a
big honor it's really big honor for me
Carrie thank you for hosting us here and
media offices of course I'm from Israel
yes I am been in China for the last ten
years with my family my father is also
here but I'm especially for this amazing
encounter with you and also my really
good friend Malik and we are so called
hustlers in China yes we content
creators for the last two three years
been hardcore inside the social medias
in China we've been making content from
different levels different types we can
get a lot of views get all directions
we're getting we're showing the world
and what is like to live in China and
this has been our like main passion now
we came here to meet you gear because
and you're also you're when you say
hustlers are you are you um York AOL's
in the marketplace yes you're also
trying to build outside of it these are
people's of you in yep exactly so our
platform is called
in English called our platform that we
set up is why China I'm personally I'm a
Kol but I'm running a media business
that creates video shows online I
understand yes I'm not really purely
okay well my name is a pure massive Kol
yes from China in China
yes I'm work platform builder creating
shows working with different like 10
cents and I Chi and Yoko and also doing
shows on your production company
production within those environments I
understand the exact what we are and
then we're here to talk about what a few
really hot Chinese topics that okay
relate to the life the internet sphere
we really want to have you back and
forth talking to you about let's do it
so I'll be your host together it's four
topics and first of all maybe I'll let
Malik and my father introduce themselves
as well let me immensely go ahead yeah
so my name is Malik and I actually study
here at Rutgers in New Jersey but I'm so
I'm a micao out in China so I create
contents about American cultures but
also some personal views on things on
you know some social issues and I have
my phone it's American and Chinese yeah
oh yeah speak Chinese and and English
yes actually came to the country like
four years ago
so I had a lot of different experience I
wanted to share with the youth in China
so that's how I started my you know my
my channel and build a million followers
in six months
yeah um Weibo and before that I was
watching your stuff and that you know it
was a huge inspiration for me thank you
you know just being being out there and
just hustle and work hard so awesome
that's amazing yeah good yeah I met pops
already in the in the elevator in 2003
what was were you in a business or
financial capitalism and think you know
so mint capita is supposed to see the
future actually don't go too far away
that's exactly right
find the right I'm aware metrics of this
I mean you've got a background yes well
we fill the China is around the corner
business-wise venture capital technology
innovation this kind of stuff and you
know Israel is good at this [ __ ]
yes very good how old was Ross when you
guys held it near us
I'm 23 this year and 13 we move but he
entered wasn't 3 when I was like I was
like 7 years old that's where he started
doing stuff in China you were flying
back and forth and and finally yeah we
so it's real you know it's not emerging
it's here it's here it's it's it's here
and now and then you have to you know
shut down to get that one fourth count
on it then the only way to do it this
move your family was racked up for you
know it's tough I have three younger
siblings will I'm the I was they're all
smaller than me we couldn't speak
ordered English actually cause in Israel
yeah we study Hebrew again in the
English level is of no people locally
very bad so took us he put us through us
in school in Hong Kong at the beginning
and later in Beijing it was tough but I
think that was made us like that really
brought us to close so close his culture
I'm so close to the Chinese culture in
so many levels like and it's really open
your world and many people had only
understand where I think or do things
because so early on I left my Israeli
friends I'd even go to the army yet
which is a shame yet but I go back he's
a pilot 24 years it was a pilot
yes like it's like it's been a tough
culture shock for me back in Israel I
didn't really serve an army but here in
China I'm a foreigner so called but I
think giving this platform social media
and this ability to express myself and
build up company under the media
gave me a place to kind of find myself
of course in China now I'm trying to
push it forward sadly we've been in
China many years but he can always speak
Chinese I can speak Chinese he got
always children to speak Chinese and
then but he understands Chinese people
think more than anyone could in many
ways so yeah that this is our little
family story love it yeah interesting
it's all right so we have we brought
some topics Gary let's go so look um we
really want people to know you in China
now we want Google you have a lot of
philosophies ways you do things that
really can spell of generation of
Chinese people now there's so many
things we're going to talk about
starting from the culture of the 90s in
China all the way to the gaming in China
which is huge now all the way to talking
about the social family pressures that
Chinese common families have which is a
big thing of their lives is really prop
if you asked me intuitively what I'm
most excited about in the next decade as
I start building my brand and my
opportunities within mainland China and
culture and in Southeast Asia in general
it is the family dynamic because that is
the most interesting insight that I've
seen from afar for the little homework
that I've done it's just a real and
listen it's you know being a Jewish
Eastern European immigrant the u.s.
similar but different it's always a
dynamic but it is extremely aggressive
in in mainland China and it and it's
funny you bring that up because that is
absolutely that I mean the next book I'm
thinking about writing is perfectly it's
called perfectly parented mmm it's a
parenting book for entrepreneurs and
more about you know your dad understands
Chinese people only because he deploys
it empathy by the way the fact you
picked this family issue is most
interesting thing because I have talked
to so many that's the key anyway we got
molecular agent you wrapped your Chinese
he looks like his family values and
stuff and but then the fourth or people
know into just talking about this like
new sanguine which means like the three
philosophies of Chinese people how they
see political correctness out will get
about to it at the end say very
interesting actually that he who also
has to say about this so let's back up
here at first so first
where this we represent is really hugely
are enlarged young audience of Chinese
people that are seeking this kind of
culture interaction of people around the
world
yes willing to learn the culture of New
York the link to another culture
American culture around the world and
willing for foreigners to learn their
culture it's really interesting age
however there is this phenomenon coming
up in China these days that people in
China see themselves as the four sheet
in Chinese which means their Buddhist
love style my question is first of all
young people 90s Millennials taking life
as like everything will come to them in
this generation because they we have
some technology so much internet so much
things is that the right approach that
people should take that's a big
advantage I don't I don't think it's is
wrong of an approach as many may think I
think given my obsession that hard work
is a pillar of variable success I'll
explain why first of all you have to
understand that it's a very common theme
when nations or people start going
through prosperity this is not something
you can stop you know when when people
talk about American Millennials when you
talk about sixty years of success in a
country you know nothing no real
negative drivers that's naturally what's
gonna happen of course older Chinese
that parents and grandparents of those
kids look at them with cynicism because
they lived in a much more difficult
environment I think that optimism is
what makes America America I think
optimism is extremely powerful
I think optimism and entitlement are a
very dangerous fine line so the answer
is as a whole I actually love it I'm
massively optimistic and I generally
believe everything's gonna be ok and I'm
very teen human being I think humans are
very underrated when it starts falling
into entitlement or if you look at
what's happening in Saudi Arabia which i
think is an interesting parallel it's
about to go through a very interesting
period with its new reforms you know
it's basically people of a state the
state's taking care of everything
you know I'm I was born in communist
Soviet Russia right Soviet Union so I
have a lot of empathy you know my
parents are a little bit different but a
lot of my parents friends really
struggled when they came to America
because they won the lottery in the
Soviet Union and had easy jobs okay
doing anything and the state would take
care of it so you know I think when you
layer technology on top of it
which means they can touch everything
you know honestly I think it's good
kamma a lot of people will get sucked
into not doing anything thus losing as
long as you can get anybody in that
generation to understand nobody nobody
is successful in being successful in
life without putting in hard work they
may inherit somebody could be wealthy
without putting in hard work it's cuz
their mommy and daddy gave them the
money but nobody is successful nobody is
successful without putting in the work
including athletes or mud I like using
models a lot of people are born pretty
true but putting in the work to you know
learn how to translate to a camera
understanding which platforms have the
attention whether that Sports
Illustrated or Instagram like it's just
work like you look at the supermodels of
last 20 years a lot of those women are
hardcore hustlers that's why they've all
had very good entrepreneurial careers
after we get tricked because they're
beautiful but they're putting in work
and so as long as you can deliver to
that generation that work is an
essential pillar of this optimistic
point of view if that's what you want
success and things great by the way if
you just want to be happy you know I
think it's a great outlook you know to
me the only thing that bothers me or
causes me caution is when people think
things come to them without putting in
the work that's all it's very simple
it's you can't get muscles without
working out and you can't get success
without working and there's a lot of
people that push back at me especially
in Europe and more liberal points of
view around too much work it's because
they're not listening to what's coming
out of my mouth my mouth that my words
are very simple as long as your work
ethic matches your ambition
you are very happy meaning if you want
to have a nice work-life balance and
have three days off a week and be
healthy and you know what have you and
recognize that you're not gonna have
mansions or reputation or books or great
I mean I think that's a to be very frank
there's a lot of times I wish that was
my ambition to me the only stress in the
system is when people's ambition aka
their mouth doesn't match their actions
there's a lot of people in on Weibo and
Instagram and YouTube saying that
they're gonna be billionaires I'm gonna
rule the world who go to forty five
music festivals a year and that is not
gonna happen so to me it's just matching
your ambition to your actions otherwise
I think it's a great thing that people
are optimistic because I think optimism
matters mm okay yes to elaborate about
you know there's a Buddhist life stuff
so it's also the young people nowadays
that they think that they're facing more
challenges and like a more competitive
environment than their parents because
they have to learn much more stuff they
have to know have much more skills you
know get going to college doesn't
guarantee anything they're right I don't
like that right so but the problem is
they're thinking about it through their
parents eyes yeah and also like with
almost like this much understand now
yeah like college to your point
especially in mainland China and high
net worth individual
the path of college then sets you up is
over yeah it's over doesn't get into you
it's just over mm-hmm like look if you
want to work at Bain and McKenzie and
Goldman Sachs big-time education you
could still have that path that's great
nothing wrong with that the problem is
the default that a college education
education the the the the petals are off
the rose like it's you know outside of
the elite top ten schools I the I think
the schools that are most dangerous our
schools 25 to 100 because they had some
brand but they don't translate they
don't translate in today's reality
anymore
it just doesn't matter and you know it
for a parent at home you know especially
in mainland China this is back to what I
jumped on
I'm very upset that you have one child
you know to your point and I don't know
every detail but I'm aware enough to
know a lot of people are single children
very the thing that I see common in in
South East culture and especially mainly
in China is that for a lot of parents
their kid is a representation of them
and that's where it breaks exactly and
that's where it breaks in Israel and in
breaks in Belarus and breaks in America
it breaks if a parent thinks that a
kid's accomplishment is a reflection on
them because now you have a disconnect
now you're not a parent and a child
you're a person with a product and I
think that that is scary to me because
going to Harvard or Stanford or Yale is
a badge that people back in Beijing walk
around proudly to their contemporaries
and they're [ __ ] their kids up that's
so true that's it that's the breakdown
so but the kids are right here's what I
would say to the kids too bad I mean too
bad that it's hard now like you have a
lot of things going for you too I
promise you right now all of you would
not switch with your grandparents yeah
the other if you're in China and you're
listening right now and you have the
option of having not college set you up
so easily or be your grandparents and
live in that communist China I have a
funny feeling you're gonna choose this
so to me I have empathy that it's
different and I have empathy that you've
been told education education education
college college college good college is
straight A's straight A's
alpha alpha dragon dragon I understand
it's changed but you're not gonna switch
with your grandparents so what are you
crying about likes about alternatives
alternate with that so what do you want
you wanna you know what do you want and
I think most people realize how good
they have it and so yes it's changed yes
there's new difficulties but it's so
much so much better than it used to be
and so I can't I can't get upset for
anybody who's living through oh darn it
my Yale education is not
to take care of me especially when a far
bigger percentage of kids from mainland
China that are going to these
universities are having it paid for by
their parents then the alternative of a
lot of Americans so what these please in
China that is an optimism
it's very optimistic point of view is
the government is now encouraging
graduates take intrapreneurship is the
first job and we see in Beijing
specialty parts of Shanghai graduates he
used to go to the government to the big
companies to follow what their parents
think yes they open their own startups
they don't startups yes the parents have
nothing to say about it because the
government endures pushing so is I think
I think that's great look America wins
because of entrepreneurship its offense
you're either on offense or defense
Europe's been on defense for 50 years
that's why Europe sucks on the global
stage of competitive business I love
Europe I love Europe for wine I was born
in Europe I love Europe for culture I
like the kindness and the empathy I love
Europe for a lot of its social points of
view except when it goes too far to the
left I love Europe but Europe can't win
you're absolved and so I think it's
great that China pushes that look I'm an
American who was born in the Soviet
Union who absolutely believes that China
has won already meaning that when I'm an
old man or when I'm gone my grandkids
are like China is the superpower I
really believe that because in China
runs its country more like a business
meaning it's a business like me
I give freedom to my team so much except
on a couple things that matter to me and
then it's a dictatorship that's more
China right so I think China's model in
a lot of ways I mean socially forget I'm
talking about entrepreneurship and
business and the Alpha stuff I think
China's got a long way to go on this
soft skills and equal rights and a
million things that make like you know
but I think you'll get there out of its
leadership so I think it's I think it's
sitting very pretty I think it's great
that it's pushing kids to
entrepreneurship my problem is nine out
of ten of these
these kids that are 22 years olds that
are jumping into entrepreneurship have
no chance cuz they're not entrepreneurs
yes because it's efficient yes but you
have to be careful because the one thing
I fear is when these kids fail and
almost all of them will it's a very big
Scarlet Letter in that culture and I
think psychologically you're putting a
23 year old in a very vulnerable spot
where now they have a loss publicly
there's no hiding when you lose in
school like I did you can blame people
when iris loses at vaynermedia she can
blame me when you work at a company or
when the government's involved or when
it's school you can blame somebody else
when you have a business it's your fault
and I the only thing I would say it's
already something that concerns me in
America where it is not a scarlet letter
to lose in business but it's but still
there's an enormous amount of because
there's so many fake entrepreneurs now
because everybody's pushing it and now
you have students who I like when I lose
I like when you guys look at me and say
he lost he did it wrong cuz I'm an
entrepreneur
but when you're a student and you get an
F it's devastating so I would caution
one thing for anybody who's listening in
mainland China who thinks
entrepreneurship is such a freedom when
you lose you have to make sure that
you're mentally stable enough to be able
to take all that cynicism and the
critiques from everybody including your
friends your friends parents your
parents because if you don't you start
going down a very dangerous path that
leads to a very scary place we do not
reconcile why we why we have suicide in
America at the teenage level it's
because modern parenting is over
coddling kids to an extreme level where
kids don't know how to deal with
adversity if you've been a great student
in the mainland China machine and you
now pop out and you start the uber or
tense end of dry cleaning and you fail I
don't want kids to go into depression
and suicide I think self-awareness
matters much more than being an
entrepreneur for you and I the learning
makes sense it's our DNA I look at every
loss as learning that is not how people
are wired so we have to be thoughtful of
we go too far
it's all college it's all
entrepreneurship we need to find the
right balance of understanding we need
to do a much better job zero to 18 to
understand somebody's makeup their
emotional makeup their skillset the way
we do school today and the way we
structure our kids for success in the
first 18 years is so broken worldwide
and so for me I'm thinking a lot about
the next 20-30 years of my life how can
i impact at least two now I impact by
putting out content and getting the 500
DMS I get every day of thank you thank
you thank you you're helping me you're a
shield that's my first step but over
time I'd like to do more because it is
the most important thing because if
you're parented well you can see it from
a mile away and when you're not you can
see it from a mile away and I think too
many parents view their kids as a
product yeah I have an idea for you may
use you said that right it's about what
you target if your target is to win to
go all the way you put everything in I
think we're going to era aware there is
like micro innovation micro interpreter
ship you don't set your goal to be the
next I agree this I agree it's a
lifestyle great I worry in my library
okay I agree it's gonna be split into
three machines lifestyle innovation I
agree I agree so much I push it very
heavily what's wrong with having a
business doing 137 thousand a year and
you're very happy selling Donuts yes I
want it very badly
you got the prop the problem is venture
capital and the modern technology media
everything's about unicorns and billion
dollars grant funding this makes it
easier Tony the venture campus you're
preaching how about how about a better
one how about just build a [ __ ]
business and work off your own cash flow
I mean Jesus Christ I mean like you know
why not just I mean vaynermedia is a 200
million dollar company I raise zero
capital I sold somebody a $60,000
consulting gig I was in a different
place in my career but I still could
have raised it like learning how to make
money is the number one skill sell
something Singles day sells trillions of
dollars of [ __ ] every year
figure it out get your game get your
$100 out of it Jesus and I mean this I
want to teach kids more to learn
to make money versus raising money
because that's a skill that never goes
away
you can always raise money later you can
and he'll tell you it's a lot easier to
raise money when you're making money all
right let's keep it as interesting ok so
just you're talking about failure and
winning and then you hear up to 23 year
olds who I think you understand young
people's mentality or what they need to
do much more than - than ourselves in a
sense I'm surprised like Hina like Gary
knows so much that is going on in China
without like surprise so there's one
thing I want to say that the thing Malik
and I would know quite well as being
like living in China and engaging in the
Internet is that there is this massive
thing going on in China that by adding
to the Buddhist mentality is that people
take on their time to play games
yes video games no bells it's a mobile
country it's completely mobilized
everyone plays on your phone and the
last two or three years you've seen like
huge calm contention among either but
companies all around the world plus
developing their own Chinese style
companies and like taking dota on League
of Legends making it in the kings of
Honor which is a very popular social
gaming when you talk about different
types of games that include many people
playing together pgb which is another
one like what I'm saying that most
Chinese people a lot of their time is
spent even with their parents during
Chinese New Year
there will be 90 percent of time like
nine games say maybe to look to win
something because it gives them a good
belonging like they feel like they're
winning that but the thing is the see
gaming culture first of what do you
think of young people being engaged
literally most of time older they eat
gaming on their free time during night
when asleep I'm Amy I'm a fan of it I'll
tell you why we've always needed
escapism true humans are very basic
we like escapism so for me if you're
asking me if I had to choose back to
life being alternatives a 16 year old
right now from 7 p.m. to 11 p.m. at
night in China playing games versus
watching television which is what her
his parents did 20 years earlier
I'm Thriller reading a book for
information that is now at their
fingertip
I'll pick gaming because I think what
it's doing is its forming behavior that
is far more relevant to today's society
as we go into a Moore machine oriented
world
the mathematical structure around gaming
psychology the things they learn the
most self-aware will realize they're
getting suckered into the gamification
of it they're chasing a carrot but we're
weeping should we chase a carrot
everywhere that's that's what humans do
we're just animals we're very easy to
understand back to winning back to
winning just to bounce a little bit I
wanted to make a point I'll use it right
here to me the people that win the most
are the ones that are addicted to the
process and the game of game of their
life much more than the things they get
from it that is oh that's the ultimate
can you love the journey the process the
work whatever you want to call it and
and to me it's so important that you
know in today's option economy with all
this technology when machines take over
all these jobs I laugh they're gonna
take over all the jobs that most people
don't like doing they just do it to get
paid what they need to pay their
mortgage or to buy things that cover up
their actual sadness I can live in a
[ __ ] basement that all this is true
and I bet you my team will agree with
this I'm a kind of person that wishes
this was our family and we all lived in
this room you know it's really funny for
me to even say that never said it that
way but it made me go right back to
where I started here not too far from
here in Queens in a small room with a
lot of family like it's fun that's it so
to me to me I think it's great I'm not
gonna frown on that because I think
about it what would those people be
doing otherwise sure no sibling it's a
big issue if you have siblings you
interact more so that's a price to pay
you know question yeah I think the note
I think the one child variable is
fascinating you know my father's a
single child my closest cousin Bobby is
a single child and I've always been
fascinated by both of them in a lot of
ways and and have always been fascinated
maybe because I'm very close to my
siblings when you were talking all that
was running through my mind was oh
that's so good that
him and his three siblings got very
close because they had each other in the
beginning when they moved not much you
know I think it's yes I think the single
child culture at scale we've never seen
scale like this is you know I don't have
real thoughts you can see I can talk
very passionate when I know I don't I
haven't thought enough about it it makes
sense but I think you know it makes
sense that they gravitate towards that
but we gravitate towards it here in the
US and Europe and other and South
America does too I think look humans
like interacting with each other it's
what we do so so nobody here is gonna
tell me that they don't feel like
they're interacting with somebody when
they're playing games when her texting
went like we are we are that's why I
love it so much
yeah I agree like my younger brother
he's in high school and all he does like
when in during a weekend he's playing
games but later I realize all of his
friends are on it and so so yeah it's a
way to socialize I say this all the time
it's the same way now social now not
less yeah yes nice to sit I used to sit
in my room by myself because I couldn't
go outside and play yeah it was 6 p.m.
mm-hmm March let me use real life
January 8th 1986 I'm in my home cuz it
got dark you know I was an 80s baby when
we played outside but now it was dark it
was cold I wasn't playing and like I was
like in my room which is by the way a
long times great too I'm sure very very
well I'm sure plenty of people are gonna
argue we have no alone time anymore
thus were over you know it's so funny to
me everybody says our kids don't know
how to engage they're not so sure I'm
like they're the reverse they're over
socialists they have no down time so to
me I think it's super interesting
I think gaming is great I think most
businesses are gonna start layering
heavy gamification psychology to
everything they do if you look at
businesses like uber and other things
around the world a lot of them grew
Spotify off of referral gamification I
think everything will have gamification
lighters on it Judaism yeah Tencent is a
company
then we can it's always the game
beginning forever also want to have
policy because the attitude you have to
do something I want to take this stuff
it leaves a deeper because there's
something in China that don't if it's
here in the US in China woman yes play
more than many dealers there's a b2i
source to travel to say it I was about
to say at that point the why is that
like what do you think of this like oh
this woman getting both could usually
imagine it's in the US and Israel and
Europe you'll see that dynamic happen in
the next 20 years as well it's because
China was further along in the mobile
culture on the gamification culture they
you know what happened singing it's
happening in Africa they leapfrogged
like American women are gonna be gaming
at scale and they do they already do
quietly on mobile because the games of
America were established far more males
focused right there were much more male
focused so that means a 42 year old male
growing up they were guy games they were
guy games he had some games like Sonic
the Hedgehog Mario you had it but it was
but in culture video games were for boys
right and not just the way it is and now
that's breaking down and you'll see this
is human gamification and game escapism
is human and we see it with candy crush
and Angry Birds we saw far more 5050
6040 once the stigma goes away which it
I think it already has you'll you'll see
far I mean especially now you're talking
you talk to 12 13 14 year old girl she's
super onboard with eSports and willing
to go there and so III don't even think
of it I think it's just the timing of
how it was introduced into the
marketplace I think most things are like
that look pink was a boys color in
Europe when it was when pink was first
introduced you know it's a boy it was a
boy's color you know in in the 1800's
in in Western Europe so like things get
manipulated heavy hands get involved
there's a lot of heavy hands on a lot of
issues and I think that's what happened
with gaming in the US and Europe but
there is no reason that should be and I
would even argue that the most
successful eSports athletes and gamers
and 25
years skew female as much as it excuse
me I'll see where are you going with you
gave me your personal life you know I
did look I think it's a you know this is
a funny time to talk about this whether
it's China whether it's a gaming whether
it's cryptocurrency
whether it's machine learning whether
there are so many trends that are
obvious to me that are foregone
conclusions in our society I I'm just a
you know as much as I've done a good job
in feeling omnipresent and pumping out a
lot I can only tackle so many things to
me everything I just mentioned there'll
be a time in a place for me to be
involved I don't need to be earliest I
just need to be executing well in places
that matter I've not been able to get
around to eSports meaning in a
meaningful way i watch all this stuff
very carefully I'm building a twitch
studio right outside my office
coming up yeah that's probably done and
what I'm maybe four or five weeks like
April first week it was it lets in a
baby I'm not gonna be gaming legend I'm
gonna be gaming the things that I can
play so you know it's gonna be you know
double dribble from a Nintendo 1986 like
you know I'm gonna throw back games I'm
gonna you know when people come through
like we would have jumped on for 10
minutes I'm gonna use it for attention
purposes blockchain you know all this
stuff this stuff I'm paying very close
attention to but I'm not deep enough yet
to execute or to speak on it I don't
like to talk about things I don't know
unbelievably well which is why I talk so
much about something very narrow which
is consumer behavior around social
layers on the Internet and I'll get you
know inevitably in the next three five
seven years one of those pillars that I
just mentioned including maybe China you
know one of the things I think a lot
about is what happens when my kids get a
little older when I can travel with them
a little bit like I I think about China
quite a bit China for me is extremely
exciting because I love the journey I
love that nobody knows me
China you know like you can just be a
normal person walking around no I can no
no I'm never normal because I can start
the process of building okay you know
enjoy the process beautiful process good
finding the right teammates to help me
doing the right things spending you know
the process like going there and
starting at zero and catching up to
everybody is the ultimate that's amazing
so let's touch a topic that you said the
beginning you really excited talking
about its parenting and also I end up
bring my father to this talk it's
exciting and then you as a parent and in
China parents is such a parenting but
their kids relation with their parents
and the all the old generation is very
not an issue but it's it's a heavy thing
on their life and Chinese near just
finished where all the kids had to go
back home and deal with different
questions and pressures of what how's
your job as you're doing you're gonna
get married like in different place in
China of different cultures it's
somewhat if it's a single biggest impact
on China if you ask me to predict go on
a prediction in 8 or 9 years I think I
will be a very substantial personality
in China because I have a very strong
passionate point of view on this issue
that I don't think is very loved by the
older generation and I think is adored
by the younger generation and they need
somebody just like the American kids
need somebody to point to to protect
them on these battles and I want to be
that person to me if you ask me what my
great legacy can be is to be the voice
of somebody who was parented extremely
well I was perfectly printed I had
parents who had those same pressures who
came from those same places who refused
to treat me that way and that's why I'm
gonna be special and and I I want that
for the good drill Ian's of kids around
the world because they deserve it
because you're absolutely right the the
the fact that 99 out of 100 parents back
in Chinese New Year put unneeded
pressure on their kids which ultimately
is going to hurt their children and hurt
their relationship with their children
is needs to start being eradicated we
need to change the conversation on on
this
and and it starts with the insecurities
of the parents yeah it's a it's an
insecurity on the parent level and it's
really you know what's really
interesting to me I think of China such
winners holistically because what the
country is doing but it is the ultimate
loser move to live to think that you are
successful based on what your children
are accomplishing I get it
like I take much more pride in what my
kids are funny or doing something
special I get it
I'm starting to really get it however it
is just wrong it is just absolutely
wrong and so what do you think oh yeah
to go deeper you know there are a lot of
new family that they're just newly
became the middle class so yeah no claps
of booming so they're afraid that
they're gonna lose because they just got
there you know like the only way that
they can think of to to maintain the
status is to invest in their kids
education or push a little bit harder to
make sure their kids can carry on the
status again also so that that's what
they're wrong yeah I understand I
understand they're gonna lose they're
gonna lose their kids and they're gonna
lose they're gonna lose their
relationship with their kids over time
what they don't understand is how
quickly the world is evolving and how
and how we're all more connected than
ever and we're all looking at each
other's cultures I think the greatest
thing that is ever gonna happen to
America is China's emergence so I think
kids that are gonna be born 10 years
from now are gonna be winners in America
40 years from now because of the chip on
their shoulder of losing that world
stage leadership I really believe that I
think America is different than Europe
that way so what should parents invest
in there okay that what aspect because
because they should invest in their
emotional and intelligence all skills a
hundred percent they what should they
invest in listening and try to figure
out their kids he you know your mother's
still you guys are still married yeah
you know that you know they have four
children they can't raise all four kids
the same way not to be not to be
ultimately successful I mean he can do
whatever he wants I don't tell anybody
to parent
listen I've
should have points of view on this but I
will never tell anybody how to parent
their child that's very personal I don't
tell anybody had to have their
relationship with their with their loved
one you know their their spouse these
are personal things it's one man's point
of view but it's one man's point of view
that you know has the luxury of being an
outlier and watching how everybody else
did it and then watching and becoming
the formative way that he looked at the
world
it's how I am as a manager to my team
there's a reason they like it it's
because I learned those skills I'm a
product of it and I would I don't wanna
be a hypocrite and treat them as
employees differently than I was treated
and they'll tell you it's I don't over
coddle it's not coddling this is this is
real love real listening real watching
with circumstances everything is is an
art and it's a child is different and
how you balance you know you want to
show the way but you don't want to
interact with their personal growth and
this man can tell you as a parent you're
only as happy as the most unhappy child
you have no like them you could have you
get up three you know he's got four of
you guys right now whoever's not in the
best place even if they're in a good
place or a solid place that's what's
running through their mind when you're
navigating something when you're
responsible same thing gives me as a
company I'm putting my finger in the
biggest holes in the boat there's a lot
of holes and so you know my you know if
this is happy you know if this trickles
out of this clip if this video catches
some virality within the mainland China
audiences on Weibo WeChat one thing I
would tell parents is do a lot more
listening and don't listen to your
[ __ ] friends you know listen to your
kids
and when I say listening watch them what
do they gravitate towards nobody thought
playing video games 20 years ago was
gonna lead to a luxurious financial life
it clearly has you know so if you're so
smart if you want your kids to be
successful recognize that the world you
live in today has nothing to do with the
world they're gonna live in nothing yeah
and so and so I - I of empathy
you know especially emerging middle
classes but if you look at America as a
proxy when the middle class started to
emerge it was also when University in
college was starting to build as a brand
and it worked for a period of time that
was fine but the problem is technology
is too much of a variable you know too
much of a variable Gary I want to want
to say something on this please we can
get on parents and parenting but I want
to take the braid off parents for a
little bit it will be go up with wider
on the culture I'm saying China is gonna
be an incredibly successful country with
a lot of unhappy people interesting so
100% so how do people kind of how do you
kind of tell this audience because you
got elope you're gonna see these videos
you see if you think money is the root
of happiness you're [ __ ] broken you've
lost you've lost life you will not win
okay that's my two cents that's good
and listen solid I'm very I'm very
empathetic I grew up in a culture very
similar like America has a lot of those
tendencies as well it's evolving which
is why it will lose more but it will be
in pockets happier you know and
everything's about balance right
everything's about balance if the least
hard-working you know country or culture
is over here and if China plays over
here the answer is always somewhere in
the middle always always always always
and look you know Israel is not short of
ambitious people and hunger for success
so you knew you guys know this I mean
look from my standpoint that is China's
vulnerability is very easy it's that I
mean if you know I wasn't aware of that
this is the first time I'm consuming
that if the default is I wish for you to
be rich so I'll give an example I would
argue that my grandmother had that point
of view and I don't think I know many
people more not happy than my
grandmother I'm thinking now of the
people that like going through my mind
that one I'm comfortable saying out loud
cuz it's within my family I don't want
to mention the two or three people I
know in the business world no question
the least happy people I know are the
ones who look at rich money as the
success barometer it leads to enormous
insecurity
yes you know what you know it's the same
reason fashion does so well in mainland
China if you think you're YSL bag or
your Louis Vuitton or your supreme is
covering up to winners your shortcomings
you're [ __ ] mistaken you might be
tricking the masses but the top 10% of
the world knows everything they need to
know when you're [ __ ] tricked out
head to toe in Louis Vuitton the most
insecure people I know are also the
people that enjoy fashion cars planes
and watches the most you cannot measure
happiness and being rich isn't by a
number it's yeah but this pressure I
mean as a young as a young person in
China you know we got the pressure of
we're hearing successful stories about
oh kids Inc yeah 25 years and making
billions and like and social media made
it has nothing to do with you construe
but it's it's just carving it's all
around you by the way I did it mm-hmm
you either succumb to it or you don't
true like you know I get it but again
back to life is about options I'd rather
kids today worry about being successful
because that's what they're being pushed
versus worrying about how to avoid the
Black Plague or run away from you know
Eastern European Poland because they're
Jewish and they're about to get killed
right or being sent off to the Korean
War or I mean like life is better like
I'm not gonna shed one [ __ ] tear for
you because this is a prosperous happy
world right now better than any other
time and if your biggest [ __ ] worry
is that you're gonna be judged by your
neighbors and friends cuz you didn't
build the next Instagram well [ __ ]
you want really I mean like listen and I
get it everybody worries about what they
worry about I have friends who are who
have 50 million dollars in their trust
fund and all they worry about is that
nobody will ever think they were good
because they were handed success and
that their life is ruined because
they'll never be successful and by the
way I get it cuz that wouldn't work for
me that would have been really bad for
me I would have struggled with that
worried that my kids have my DNA and are
gonna struggle with being on third base
it's so everybody has their own
realities but here's the punchline my
friend you have no choice like it is
what it is
like it's a good problem to have okay
that's that that kind of takes us into
like the last topic because home is
getting to 11 a.m. and I know you're
busy Gary so this entire we talked about
in very different social issues and in
China there is thing on the internet
it's very something that started off
very early in the education system in
China but the way that people value a
judge somebody a lot of times are played
to a constable the three positives and
that's something Malik knows about
someone it's basically a combination of
the three it's called sanguine and one
is called personal values yeah second
life philosophy yeah and third worldview
okay the three views is the three kind
of posit okay and a lot of time people
use this cause in China because the
political environment is different
yes it's a way to judge somebody's
behavior whether he's more Pro woman or
pro and development or it's a way to
judge people's philosophies in life okay
and a lot of times Malik is the easy
kind of either social okay well he
creates his opinion he puts it out there
if you want to tackle social issue and
he's known as like the most the these
three positive is the most correct of
all like he is extremely a great example
of this now the way do you think people
in the internet when they try to program
kind of express themselves do should I
worry about how people judge them
constantly on their values is being a
person with really positive great values
of life more liberal values because
unity in the u.s. is that something that
someone should take when they're trying
to push themselves to live in society
you should like be like three
prearranged values in your system which
can you design it yourself
that's the first question then on that
like you know a lot of kids watch myself
and they really I have a good like the
values but I was actually tripped or
prisoned by these value I can't I can't
like I cannot say stuff outside of what
is view to be right like the political
correctness you know sometimes I want to
on extend a little bit and
different ideas different opinions but
oh you know like that there are people
jump onto the comment section and
started firing about you're not on the
right track of you're not following what
is view to be right in the society I
think like ignoring different ideas and
different voices it is it's really
dangerous
young people's the pressure to be kind
of so here's my two cents on this the
biggest thing that you guys don't know
that we know as the older statesmen in
the room is that the state of
politically correct abuse changes all
the time true what what him you know
what he grew up with what I then grew up
with it's changed you know to me I don't
sit on you know I mean I am the most Pro
human person I the thought I would die
if I was to suppress another human being
in any shape or form
for me to judge or do something negative
to another human being literally breaks
my soul like the thought is so foreign
like I can't even comprehend the ability
to when I watch the world or my friends
or neighbors or associates or
politicians on the world stage America
Russia China anywhere it's the single
worst thing you can do especially in
today's environment where everything's
being documented you will lose
historically your legacy will be tainted
so for me I could never do the wrong
thing by another person however I do not
take the liberal point of view on every
social issue I do not believe that I
believe that we've gone too far in
America by giving kids trophies if they
come in fifth place I'm just not
I don't have the liberal point of view I
do not believe in unions that is not I
don't I don't think that that's a good
idea I think taking the fair market out
of it is bad I come from the Soviet
Union I know what happens when you go
too far right I think that there's a lot
of laziness in China that people don't
talk about because of those undertones
and certain especially if they aren't
just emerging in the middle class they
started at the right so I think you know
you will lose if you are scared to put
out your tube set here's here's the
number one thing I will tell you for you
and anybody else who's listening who's
playing
this game when you die on a sword it's
much more fun to die on your own sword
so when you lose by living a public life
on an issue that you didn't fully
believe in to begin with it's gonna hurt
double you know as far as people leaving
comments that doesn't even penetrate my
mindset and both ways both ways most of
my comments is I'm the greatest and the
greatest human being that ever lived I'm
the greatest doesn't penetrate just as
much as somebody saying I'm wrong or am
a charlatan or they hate me both the
same which is I'm appreciative anybody's
paying attention to the begin with I'm
grateful and that's where it kind of
stops and starts you know somebody
anonymous on the internet saying I suck
or that I'm somebody you know better
than that
really I don't my 1 cent is done by
others people comment at the same time
listen to them always always you have to
be thoughtful you can never get too high
on your own supply and that's I was
saying the same thing which is whether
they say I'm the greatest or I'm the
worst it's one in the same and I think
people are selective they love the
positive feedback and they block the
negative feedback I probably spend a
little more time on the negative
feedback than the positive feedback
because I want to be thoughtful and I
never want to become a caricature of
myself or I'm getting too high on myself
but I also don't over stress around the
negative feedback because I'm empathetic
I understand why they're giving it to me
mm-hmm good so yeah another actual
question I want to ask please before
myself and also a lot of stress we can
go a couple minutes into doing it here
we'll talk a lot about China but what
about New York so kids like me or
foreign kids and yes I shot a bow you
know we want to make it here yeah
especially New York nobody dreams like
you yes like how look what does it take
to make it I think it takes the same
thing that takes to make it in Beijing
or or anywhere in the world telling me
like it's the same old game you have to
assess the situation mm-hmm you have to
understand what value you can provide
and you have to understand what your
ambitions and goals are I mean look I
think that places like New York or
London or Tel Aviv for that matter or or
Beijing
Shanghai and on and on and on these are
special places this is where a lot of
people are this is where the A+ talent
is and it's congregating and every
situation is different I think the one
great thing America has is it's got a
lot of shortcomings like any other part
of the world but the government
intervention on entrepreneurship and
capitalism is far less which creates a
much more even playing field which is an
awfully exciting and intoxicating
feeling just as a justice you know I
think where American business men and
women get confused about being
successful in China and I've watched so
many of them and it must be funny for
you actually going through that
transition watching everybody come in
with a lot of puffy chest and getting
annihilated as they underestimate the
market they underestimate the skill set
of the people and the actual pure bred
entrepreneurship but what they also
underestimate is the government period
end of story
I have the luxury of being born in a
place where that was very much the case
so it's always been in the back of my
mind China is not America it's you know
you don't have you have to be very
thoughtful of your relationships with
the government or you will not succeed
at the level that you decide you're
gonna succeed at or more importantly it
sucks you into a certain level and then
it really hurts your feelings so you
know I think making it in New York for
somebody in China who's a young kid
fresh off the boat is very exciting
because some of the things that they've
always thought were in play are actually
not a negative in this market and that's
that's obviously very exciting people
who were born you know friends
understand things you don't understand
your
a shortcoming with you have a card do
that about it right so like bring would
bring what you have to here instead of
brother like brother it's huge it's huge
the amount of a and B list business
people I know that are desperate to form
relationships with in the US with you
know Chinese kids you know luminaries
influencers care wells business people
you know the biggest reason that I'm not
building my brand in China is time like
time of being on the ground and so
there's a lot of people who have that
issue it's an enormous advantage to be
able to speak the dialect anybody who
right now can speak both those languages
is off to the [ __ ] races and the
reality is there's a hell of a lot more
Chinese that are able to do it than
Americans for now right that will change
over the next 20 years as we start
introducing it way more into the
education system and Education America
changes most of the kids I know that are
eight nine ten that can speak Mandarin
are not doing it within their school
they're doing it outside of their school
and so I think we'll see more of that as
Americans realize that's a cost of entry
to win on a global stage unless
technology catches up I actually think
by the time we teach everybody
translation we've got it in our ear like
I think I could happen but he goes to
the soft skill understanding the culture
is more important than the language
right always the culture so here have
really good follow-up question carry
this please really really important for
us because so we're talking week we have
do EV influence in China we built it
with a lot of empathy patient in time we
didn't just go viral like this course
not we were I think his story my story
he's from the dorms here in New York
trying to make videos and slowly asks us
building different kinds of formats and
it took us time and patience to enter
China and yes and show them the
foreigner point of view about China
that's what we do yes are our main
selling point in China is that we show
for Chinese people how we enjoy or
appreciate or think of different Chinese
trends I understand this is very very
great however my bigger dream personal
dream is I wanna I think that the world
is so much more open to more people to
see this country itself beside of the
Chinese because so many more
our biggest dream is to bring it here to
Facebook YouTube Instagram to show more
people what is life in China like and
so we built a brand called white shine
with capital why why China but again as
you said to enter a new mark in their
place
it takes the person I grew up ten years
in China I'm completely non westernized
many of my thinking yes I haven't been
involved in Facebook as much they
haven't been spending ninety nine
percent of my time on Chinese social
networks and one for search
so with that time and empathy needed to
enter this market with our content to
show the world were strong Americans you
could per say what is China like what
are things that attract Americans about
China that are currently relevant can be
in the next two or three years what are
the main topics that you think I should
spend time exposure I don't do
everything so look I think the biggest
problem with America is it's so American
biased right America's biggest
shortcoming is that it's been the leader
of the world for too long and it's
gotten high of its own supply America's
answer to anything when somebody else is
doing something well is that they're
cheating or corrupt it's a very big very
big vulnerability I think the reason I
love the Olympics the reason I love
social media like open communication
solves every issue like it's just true
so to me I just think it's the truth
I think you know I think what you need
to do if you want that is you need to
become the practitioner and the executor
in a YouTube Facebook Instagram snapchat
podcast world the same way you are in a
way Bo WeChat you know world so you know
to me I don't think it's about the
content I think as long as you tell the
truth I mean people are fascinated by
you just I think well let me give you a
couple things I would do I would
definitely do interviewing people on the
street around things that are happening
in America a video that would do very
well in the US on social media is a
one-minute video mashup of seven
people's answers on Instagram of what
people in China think about Instagram
and you doing the clever job of showing
seven people that had never heard of it
or seven people talking about well they
loved it when they did a semester at
UCLA so I think taking content that is
happening in the u.s. like asking you
know I think 40 people for three minutes
answering their thoughts on LeBron James
in China is an interesting insight so
taking things that are trending in
America and asking and making videos one
to five minute videos of normal Chinese
citizens young and old giving their two
cents you know if you called it like two
yen you know there's something like that
like it would be really interesting for
Americans to see the perception of their
brands and culture outside yeah you're
right on your right on because what got
was so popular in China is the fact he
was talking about things trending the
hundred islands in the opposite exactly
the flip mirror this would go 100
percent okay and then what about some
summer support I'm going to use the time
everything Gary is that Vox vice they
make this kind of internal more deep
like more informative but like also
really realistic like documentaries
right and we actually did some shows
showing me working in Chinese beams to
the Chinese delivery boy working Chinese
train's engineer I was being very
documentary level like really trying
heavily show people the real life there
yes is that also direction that
Americans would like to see or is this
things unless humans wanna see truth yes
my documentaries work right that's why
new platforms when they emerge
documentaries over always over index
that's why Netflix is doing so well with
them the truth always wins and then we
start melting it I'm making less truth
but the truth is always the answer okay
you know me better of Facebook than our
interviews videos but again I'm just
saying that don't get caught up in
short-term social media analytics as an
indicator to what works my youtube
channel views on my daily vlog haven't
moved in a year by all by all metrics
not working I'm just completely unfazed
I'm aware because I pay attention to my
[ __ ] but I'm not going to pander to
creating something that doesn't feel
authentic to me to get 200,000 views per
episode instead of 50 that has no value
in the long game just think to ourselves
be real we do our content it's always
gonna be the best all right I got a run
yeah thank you
[Music]